the kardashian-jenner mothers-to-be  celebrate Halloween you can just be  someone different you can join with  every him Khloe and Kylie went all out  for the holiday this year we'll kick  things off with the youngest 20 year old  Kylie she went as an angel while her  bestie Jordan Woods was a devil Kylie  made sure to crop her baby bump out of  all social media posts on Tuesday while  her big sis Chloe actually showed off  what appears to be a still flat tummy  while paying tribute to Game of Thrones  with her man Tristan Thompson and  laughing Khloe and Kylie have yet to  confirm their pregnancies but Khloe  might have given a nod to the news with  her caption on this snap of Tristan then  there's Kim she channeled the late great  Selena and seemingly didn't think twice  about showing off her midsection  she and her hubby Kanye West are  expecting their third child via  surrogate early next year  [Music]  you